I'm sitting here with Mike one of the
web developers at Udacity um I heard you
wrote some pretty bad code recently yeah
that was quite the experience yeah I
actually remember because I gave you
that mad easy assignment you did so so
basically in a nutshell what did I tell
you to do oh you came up with an app
idea and you just told me all right now
forget all things you know to do right
and and do it wrong and try and make it
a rough experience so builds spaghetti
code app build a spaghetti good
application and how did you feel I was
really excited because I knew I didn't
have to maintain this thing I was just
gonna crank out an application for you
really quick get it done in an hour to
and and just get code on the screen and
feel super productive so I was I was
kind of excited to not have to put a
whole lot of brain power to it and just
do it yeah it's kind of old habits right
right because everyone kind of learned
spaghetti code and then learns how to
organize their code later on it reminded
me of like 10 years ago like the type of
work i was doing so um you had this app
you didn't have to maintain it you felt
great about it and how do you feel be
the end pretty bad really why well it
was a miserable experience when it got
to the end there was a point that I
actually coated myself into a corner I
had a problem that I knew like I knew
myself was a simple problem to solve but
because of the way I had built the
application it was no longer a simple
problem to solve it was actually really
difficult and then I just felt bad
because I knew where this code was going
I see well actually Nick artman one of
our other friend and engineers likens it
to diving for the finish line yeah and
if you dive for the finish line too
early well you get scraped up right and
things were really bad and it takes a
lot more effort to go then and finish
the the race dumb that's a very good
metaphor I basically told you to die
right over the starting block right yeah
I I thought I was done with the
application before I had ever even
started it really and so I was just
trying to get stuff done and if I would
have taken my times like
really plan it out ahead of time and and
know what I was going to do throughout
everything it would have been a much
more enjoyable experience all right so
if you want to blame someone for this
experience you can blame Mike you told
me to do it if you want to blame someone
for this experience you can blame me I
suppose awesome well thanks Mike for
sitting with me